hola qué tal sucede que en bolivia el
recuento oficial de datos se realiza de
la siguiente manera una vez que se
produce la votación las actas son
trasladadas en físico hasta las
capitales de departamento donde los
vocales recuentan los votos y acta por
acta pero hay algunas poblaciones muy
remotas entonces este traslado puede
tardar hasta días e incluso en algunos
casos se realiza a lomo de mula porque
son comunidades muy alejadas de las
capitales en todo caso les comento que
en las últimas horas el conteo oficial y
ha superado el 55 por ciento de las
actas y se puede ver ya la tendencia que
da como ganador a luís arce
estos resultados oficiales hasta este
momento establecen que el movimiento al
socialismo ha sacado 48 por ciento
comunidad ciudadana 32 por ciento y
creemos 16 por ciento sin embargo
todavía falta contabilizar el 45 por
ciento de las actas y esto podría
suceder hasta este viernes
mary como queda luego de las elecciones
el movimiento al socialismo ni más
el expresidente morales
el movimiento al socialismo se ha
consolidado como el principal partido de
bolivia y además ha demostrado que es
capaz de renovar sus liderazgos porque
sin evo morales ha logrado una mejor
votación que el año pasado el año pasado
morales había logrado un 45 por ciento
de los votos en las elecciones que han
sido anuladas mientras que arce en la
actualidad ha logrado 4 el 53 por ciento
por otro lado el gran debate que existe
en este momento es qué va a pasar con la
figura del ex presidente evo morales
incluso dentro del más existen
discrepancias pues algunos dirigentes
consideran que se debe volver de una vez
el ex presidente a bolivia pero otros
dicen que no es el momento todavía él ha
tenido una comunicación ayer con los
cocaleros del chapare a quienes les ha
pedido preparar su regreso y de hecho
ellos están trabajando en ese sentido y
la gran duda es también si es que luis
arse continuará siendo el del fin de evo
morales o asumirá más bien una
presidencia auténtica y que responda
sólo a sus visiones del país de parte de
luis arse
venid gracias por la información feliz
resto de días